yo creo que se debe tomar este anuncio
de forma escéptica
recordemos que no es la primera vez que
hay un conflicto entre ambos países y no
es la primera vez que rompen relaciones
ya de hecho es la segunda vez que
intentan retomar las relaciones Creo que
este conflicto es más profundo de lo que
aparenta estamos hablando de un país
guiado por una ideología
neotomanista O sea que quieren ser el
líder del mundo musulmán Zurita frente a
el estado de Israel que continúa sus
conflictos con los palestinos por lo
tanto no es que de un día para otro va a
terminar ese conflicto por lo tanto va a
haber nuevas razones para que los turcos
se quejen contra Israel Gabriel también
como lo estábamos hablando de la pasada
crisis de que llevó al retiro mutuo de
Los Embajadores ocurrió en 2018 tras la
muerte de estos 60 palestinos a manos de
la fuerza de israeías porque entonces la
retoma ahora en los momentos cuando
acaban de ocurrir nuevamente ataques en
casa que dejaron casi 50 muertos
porque erduan tiene serios problemas
económicos internos muy serios y también
tiene un desprecio general de todo el
medio oriente el medio oriente sunita
despreciardogan y desprecia Turquía y la
política de Turquía en el medio oriente
por lo tanto fíjate súmale una cantidad
de variables importantes la primera una
cantidad de turistas que llegan a
Turquía desde Israel de forma continua y
ese flujo de personas
se estaba cortando eso por un lado pero
más importante aún Israel ha firmado un
acuerdo estratégico con chipre y con
Grecia para el paso de un tubo de gas
que se descubrió las costas de Israel
para poder suplir Europa Turquía está
muy preocupada por eso porque prefiere
que ese flujo de gas pase por su
territorio Isabel evidentemente no va a
supeditar la otra Alianza con chipre y
con Grecia esta nueva amistad con
Turquía a pesar de que erdogan sí lo
desea claro Gabriel ya por último cómo
será recibido este anuncio en la
comunidad Palestina que Turquía asegura
seguir apoyando en sus causas
la palabra es pasividad realmente no es
un tema que ha influido mucho en Israel
tampoco mucho en Turquía no ocupado
lugares importantes en las noticias
porque realmente según el diario de
Turquía por supuesto los diarios
opositores que son pocos lo notan como
algo que es una un cambio de política de
Turquía a quien Israel no ha sido
algo que ha llamado la atención especial
hay una desconfianza general hacia
erdogan y dentro de la calle Palestina
lo toman como algo momentáneo ya que
Turquía va a seguir apoyando a la causa
Palestina lo que pasa la pregunta
Central es si desde Turquía va a seguir
actuando jamás jamás tenía su sede ahí
en Turquía en muchos aspectos Y eso era
algo que preocupa también la autoridad
Palestina y también Isra